- I'm gonna look like Seacrest after this.
(laughs softly)
That's, well no, Debra
Seacrest, my old neighbor.
(crowd laughs)
(royal music)
- We're getting facials!
I feel like I'm gonna be
a whole new person after this.
(laughs)
- I know nothing about facials.
I don't pay attention to
my face. I know it's here.
- In preparation I have not washed
my face in the last week, so.
Yeah I did.
- I'm excited just because
I'm really into, like,
my face. You know, my face.
- I'm gonna look beautiful!
Am I gonna look like a baby when I'm done?
Just like a little baby face?
- Basically, we're gonna wash
your skin with an exfoliant
that removes and loosens up the dead skin.
And then we're gonna do an enzyme,
which actually dissolves the dead skin,
and preps the skin for extractions.
- Do I look like Apolo
Ohno in this headband?
- Do you have a normal skin care routine?
- Soap.
- Oh yeah.
- When I close my eyes
and the steam in my face
kind of feels like a summer breeze I mean.
- Enzymes are like the
Pac-Man of skin care.
- This is eating my face right now.
- It's eating your face.
- I'm good. Beauty is pain.
(laughs)
- So I am just gonna
place these on your eyes.
- Is this a good look?
- It's a great look!
- Oh God, oh God! Oh no!
(laughs)
- I apologize in advance.
- Oh, this is wonderful!
- (laughs)
These are cool globes, so
they help with redness,
inflammation and they tighten the pores.
So they're gonna feel
really cool on your skin.
- Okay
- Okay?
- Probably not that cold.
- Alright.
- Oh!
(laughs)
- Woo!
- Dancing little ice globes,
dancing across my face.
This is everything that I want forever.
- (laughs)
- Woah!
(laughs)
Woah! I'm getting car washed.
- Do you want some water?
- Friends. Like I'm so
glad I got this bib off
so everyone can just see.
- Oh my God what is this?
- That is my chest.
(laughs)
- Woah! Yeah I look crazy!
I feel spectacular!
- It was amazing. It was just so,
it was an all-body experience.
- This is amazing. I've
never felt this clean before.
Also my face is like, is like I'm
touching somebody else's face.
- I didn't realize it would
be as relaxing as it was.
- The softest skin I think
I've ever felt in my life.
- I feel kind of blissed out.
- And my nose.
- I actually feel like a baby's butt so,
you know, goal accomplished.
(laughs)
- After this I might do
it every couple of months.